Hello You Tube I'm Ian Bremmer and I'm taking
about whether or not Obama is going to make
a difference for the better in 2009. He certainly
isn't going to make a difference for the worst,
but the question is how much he can really
do. No one here at the world economic forum
really thinks that the economy is going to
improve significantly before 2010. So there
are limitations there. And secondly there's
a question of just how much time and effort
the Obama administration is going to be able
to actually put outside of the United States.
And I'm sitting here at Davos, I was actually
asked the other day on CNBC, about whether
I was sad that there weren't any Americans
here. I said well I'm an American I should
be making you happy. Of course they're talking
about the Obama administration. In fact there
are just no foreign policy officials. The
Obama administration is going to be focused
almost exclusively on dealing with the domestic
economy. And that's the reason why Gates was
reappointed as secretary of defense. You have
a lot of great special envoys with a lot of
experience, but at the end of the day you
really wanna make it better. The president
would have to spend an awful a lot amount
of time on the ground, on the road. And in
2009 I don't expect that's gonna happen. So
long term I think there's going to be a honey
moon. Obama is going to be more multi lateral
in form and in content. We already saw in
Aljezera that he's reaching out to modern
Islamic communities around the world. I thought
that was very effective. This is a guy who's
going to ask the Europeans for more trips
in Afghanistan. We'll probably have some success
there. I think the world in generally rooting
for Obama with very few exceptions. But in
2009 do I think he's going to make a fundamental
and structural difference in the world? I'm
balanced no. Thanks a lot.